暑いといえばみんなはどうしますか
そう
暑さから逃げるというわけで北海道に行ってまいりました
[音楽]
一人ですあの笑えないけど屋ついんですよ日本がもう地域によっては3040入ってる
ということでもうさすがにたいけませんということで私今回北海道に来ておりますと
別件でやることができたんでハグ web のマネージャーさんと一緒に2人でき
てるんですけどもうまず北海道きた瞬間の人事もいいですか
本当に寿司混ぜ手続シーンですよもう訳でまぁちょっと
ゆるっとした動画最近はまとってなかったってまあ夏休みゆるっと
まあ一人北海道の旅1泊2日なんですけども
アプリしていこうと思いますけどちょっとなりな
7マネージャ
口ず俺の東京とかねもうね
高級できないじゃあ次て仮殿くる大人
何かんね
てるぽいんだよん
[音楽]
ただコンビニ彼方たんですねできますよ
まず峰体感させたいこの拳たーーー
涼しいー
た今日は素敵涼しくないすか北海道飾ったんだよね
もしつか涼していてやばいんだ
俺は北海道にいない人間なんだよん
5 f
上に入った
やっぱ嫌なんだろうな俺がいるのがとレーザーの何がともあれ北動画の編集があるんで
その北海道ぽいお店行って国会のありこことここだね北菓楼って書いてる私がめっちゃ
オレンジ色になことっていいのかなぁとでちょっとあの僕も帰って動画の編集が残っ
てるんで
なあ国会ところも買ってコンビニで買い出しして
ちょっと編集に戻り
ますよっしゃ勝った公園とかあったら嬉しいなって感じですねこれは空がもう秋
ちょちょ止まってやばいなーちょっと謎な北海道よすぎるなぁ2東京都傘暑い場所に
住んでいる人は絶対行ったほうがいいです夏の北海道
これ本当にはちょっとねぇ北海包もうか迷うくらいね気に入っている今
公園ないなぁ応援とかもうこれさえ増えればいいんですけどこれ食って編集頑張ります
やっぱりです1人役だからさあ寂しかったった一のビアガーデンやってる
いやがんねはい
いないなそこで者はカーンそうなの4月からホテルってめちゃくちゃ大きいですよ
フェアバーたが人多いなぁぜってーもキャーってなりますよね
それすごい
ああああ
めっちゃする人生北海道
me
ハズレああああ下旬
かれあそうなんですよ
アリ道は覚えジュークに報いてで分かった
まったく入ってにあれ
また来週クリームくれない
[音楽]
結構いろんな人が声をかけてくれて嬉しいですね頑張ってる帰ります
岩瀬うれしい
はーいっ where
[音楽]
ああああああ
スタバれここここ
いやー
[音楽]
me
シャア
バーガー一変後バーナーん
イヤンチャー
[音楽]
俺よりてんなーコレだがあれだな北海道で有名な建物です
これ見たが張るもこれだってこれなら8日見るやつな気がするんですよね
どこで見たかわかんないんですけどねんかこれ北海道をといえば札幌といえばコレ
みたいなやつだと思いますねかっこいいなぁでも入ろうかな
[音楽]
廃炉というわけでちょっとパズドラやってたら起きる過ぎになってたんでもう結構帰り
の飛行機が使いので
札幌といえば何があるかちょっとわかんないんですけどちょっと調べますか
はいうわぁああ楽しいあえてぐちょっと調べたんですけどなんだけど百合が原公園
みたいな公園がねーなーが調べたらめっちゃ綺麗だったのでそこに行こうと思います
まあ
4黄色い受理ガラ公演までお願いしますはいはい
はい安倍氏にかけた発布こういう金なんかジュリーが丘公園でと黄金なんかネットで見
たとき凄いきれいだったんでちょっと見てくけ
ね人は少ないうわーこぴっぐわぁ
[音楽]
いいきれい
北海道感が出てますねー
[音楽]
亜未あっ
おばさんかつでしたあなんか公園ポイントが出てきた
北海道満喫してる感が出来ましたねーうわぁおっ
映像って感じができる良い
無事間に合いましたマジで結構ギリギリ
[音楽]
goo
ブーシェ
2分
プー
いきましたーーー
日本の気候はいい
あつっ
[音楽]
me
uh
car
me
うんいいでしょうかいませんねあれでよろしい